à travers la politique commerciale à
travers nos accords de commerce on
exporte notamment des biens et des
services m'ont exporte aussi nos valeurs
les états unis agissent sur plusieurs
niveaux pour limiter la volonté de
certaines entreprises d'aller sur
d'autres territoires
comment concrètement en fait ça peut
être avec la mise en place d'embargos
dès que vous utilisez le dollar et on
sait le poids de cette monnaie sur la
scène internationale dès que vous
commercer avec un autre état et que vous
passez par exemple par des serveurs
américains
dès l'instant en fait qu'il y a un lien
avec leur territoire il utilise les lois
extraterritoriales il ya différentes
lois donc sur le terrorisme sur la
corruption sur le domaine fiscal et ils
nous empêchent justement deux dalles et
commercer comment en fait en disant si
vous commercer vous perdez l'accès à
notre marché où vous allez avoir des
amendes
on va entamer une procédure
juridictionnelle et qu'est-ce qui se
passe nos entreprises elles ont un lien
avec le marché américain qui est un
marché extrêmement important donc elles
font des choix stratégiques et elles se
disent je ne vais pas abandonner le
marché américain
donc je renonce à d'autres marchés et
c'est ça en fait la limite de notre
liberté et de notre souveraineté de
notre capacité aussi à ne plus être
seulement dépendante des amériques
l'extraterritorialité représente à mon
sens une menace pour l'europe pourquoi
parce que on voit bien il est question
de liberté
les questions de souveraineté il est
question aussi surtout de conformité
avec le droit international
comment l'union européenne peut-elle
réellement agir avec efficacité contre
eux les dérives de l'extraterritorialité
il ya plusieurs leviers ya les leviers
juridiques avoir une législation qui
soit un petit peu en effet miroir de la
législation américaine se muscler
renforcer son arsenal juridique
et puis il ya la volonté aussi de mieux
travailler avec nos entreprises avec
d'autres partenaires pour limiter le
poids des états unis et l'union
européenne
elle doit démontrer que à travers de
nouveaux accords elle protège réellement
ses ambitions ses valeurs et ses
intérêts
moi en tant que vice présidente de la
commission du commerce international
je pousse la commission européenne je
pousse les états membres a enfin avoir
des outils efficaces opérons pour que
les autres za respecte les règles du jeu